installation on rentre à l'intérieur
nous sommes l'échelle les policiers son
public nous rejoindre si les policiers
font pas un mètre 66
c'est km 66 et la taille en fait des
moyennes des gens c'est assez étonnant
s'ils paraissent petit comme dans le
cadre du panorama de la sculpture
contemporaine organisé ici as a rock
nous pouvons voir se croiser deux
oeuvres assez étonnante l'une de xavier
veilhan sans titre les policiers de 1993
et l'autre de bertrand lavier walt
disney productions de 1947 1995
l'enjeu ici c'est de comprendre qu'avec
la sculpture la tridimensionnalité
renvoie effectivement à une illusion
plus précises peut-être qu'en peinture
mais que cette dernière évidemment chez
ces deux artistes se côtoient dans un
espace qui n'est que fiction nous
demandons à voir une caméra plus légère
la prochaine fois merci
d'abord la pièce de xavier veilhan ces
sept policiers qui jalonnent comme cela
l'espace nous semble évidemment sorti de
nulle part rattaché à la municipalité de
paris nous avons effectivement des
sculptures semblant par leurs costumes
renvoyer à une présence humaine mais
dont la certaines inexactitudes que l'on
peut y voir par ce travail de la résine
nous amène à voir cette friction
classique chez xavier veilhan de ce
petit jeu évidemment du dépassement de
la réalité on repart du centre alors
c'est horrible c'est une très mauvaise
idée fait de faire des images tout temps
monsieur s'élève à 6 17 policiers ont
des regards concentrant par rapport à
l'installation d'autels éveillant mais
l'un semble être plus autonome tourné
dans le cadre de la mise en scène car il
faut savoir que la pièce deux élèves
ayant et à adapter aux lions la présente
c'est une vraie installations celui ci a
été volontairement tourné ici pour faire
face à l'oeuvre de bertrand lavier comme
si la surveillait clin d'oeil renvoyant
évidemment à cet épisode du journal de
mickey ou mickey minnie vienne enquêter
dans un musée d'art moderne dans le
cadre de vols évidemment d'un certain
nombre d'oeuvres lavier sont amusé et
donc en ressortant ses sculptures de la
fiction même de walt disney il nous
amène à voir une oeuvre qui remis dans
un musée redevient un objet artistique
alors que ce n'était au début qu'un seul
décor nous voilà donc bien dit on nous
déstabiliser dans une exposition où dès
cette première salle nous nous trouvons
à dialoguer entre fiction et réalité
d'un objet qui nous est beaucoup plus
accessible peut-être que la peinture
mais qui reste étonnamment artistique
c'est à dire dégagé aussi du réel ce que
tu as ici tu vois très bien là sans
résine ces deux ans après par eysines on
peut la faire très très lisse sûr que ça
peut vraiment être une forme parfaite
donc on comprend bien que ici à
rechercher kelly c par rapport à l'image
première de walt disney productions de
cette question de l'image de bandes
dessinées et que ici au contraire on
comprend que veillant il veut rester
absolument dans l'artificiel il n'est
pas dans le trompe l'oeil plus on
s'approche de ses oeuvres plus en fait
on va dire que tous sont nommés tisme
s'écroule pour laisser place en fait
qu'une sculpture c'est plus petit
salaire c'est ainsi une poupée c'est
quelque chose qui est venu manipulable
voilà
moi je vous joins ces mamans qu'un vol
un smic m a innocenté surtout qu'il ya
un rebondissement dans le scénario
mickey le premier criminel arrêté n'est
pas le bout c'était simplement un
complice
pour ça je vous renvoie numéro 2279 du 2
janvier 1977 du journal de mickey